>> Mark Dimunation:
Welcome, everybody.
Hi. I'm Mark Dimunation, Chief
of the Division here and welcome
to another Thursday at Three.
I was going to wait ten minutes
because Michael was pacing,
but it just seemed
cruel [laughter].
So, so we're going to start on
time just to spare him that.
We're amongst friends here
but, in case you don't know,
Michael Platt and
Carol Beane, do I -
do we need the middle initials?
Michael B. Platt and Carol A.
Beane have been collaborating
on visual imagery and
artist book creations
for a good 18 years now,
since their first volume came
into the Library of
Congress in 2001.
So, we're in for - and Carol, in
particular, is a familiar face
at these lectures and is
known to many of us here
in Washington as
are both of them.
So, we're really pleased
to have them here together,
and it's going to be
one of those moments.
Michael creates - he's a
printmaker, but he now prefers
to be called an image
maker, is that correct?
>> Michael Platt: Yeah.
>> Mark Dimunation: Yes,
because he makes images,
rather than prints.
And this can range from,
as I'm sure you will hear,
from small portfolios
to large walls
in school buildings,
recently, yes?
So, from print to mural.
Carol is a poet,
has been inspired
by the African Diaspora, but
also some other experiences
that have led her to
create, in some cases,
poetry that plays on
call and response.
And, together, the poetry
and the images are combined
into a single experience
which is quite moving.
You've had a chance to see
some of them and you're welcome
to come take a look
at them as well
after they're through speaking.
But it's a real pleasure
to have both of them here.
Would you please welcome them?
[ Applause ]
>> Michael Platt: I would just
like to thank you
all for coming out.
I feel like I'm playing
the big house,
this is like the how we did
in the '50s so [laughter].
It's really great.
I would like to really thank
my wife who had the nerve
to bring the first
book we did up here.
I thought she's out
of her mind, you know,
barely made an appointment.
She came up and she
came back home
with this big ass
grin on her face.
And I didn't even want to
know what happened, you know,
but it was - it was
good, it was really good.
And, from there, we
just kept making books.
The first book we made was a -
I guess it was fulfilling
a promise she made
to her father who
had passed away.
She was supposed - what
were you writing it on?
>> Carol Beane: Slavery
in Black America.
Images of, and literary
correspondences.
>> Michael Platt: But
that didn't have anything
to - he passed away.
So, I said, "Carol, we're
going to make a book
and dedicate it to your father".
What are we going
to make a book on?
My images, her poems.
And, since I always had side
projects of making things,
I think that's what artists
do, they like to make things.
So, I decided to
make a little book.
And then we put it
together and we got lucky
in this collection, so.
>> Carol Beane: I think
one of the things, too,
that inspired me as well
Michael is Pyramid Atlantic,
whom I think most of you are in
the D.C. area are familiar with.
Michael used to go out there
and print, and he was invited,
when they got the
really huge printer,
to make the inaugural
print on that.
But you can't - you couldn't be
- you can't, and couldn't be,
at Pyramid Atlantic
without people all
around you doing books and
making paper and everything.
It was just wonderful.
And I would go home
and I would think,
that looks like something that's
really interesting and fun.
So, the object was, it's
always been very important.
And then, my brother and I grew
up in a household with parents
who were New Yorkers and
we always had a library,
like a separate room
that was the library.
So, if you're a New
Yorker from the city,
you know, they're from Harlem.
Then you go to New York Public
Library and you're in Harlem,
you go to the Schomburg
Center and, in fact,
he worked on that during
WPA days, way back when.
So, there was all that.
And then he came to Howard as a
student, so he actually worked
at the Library of Congress.
That was one of his jobs back
in the late '30s, early '40s.
So, it's wonderful to be
here and so I thank Mark
and I thank John Cole who was
the Director for the Center
for the Book, I don't know if he
still is, I hope so, who said,
"You need to go over and
talk to Mark Dimunation".
And then, the familiar faces and
people who I've gotten to know
and Christina Wasserman,
because someone said,
"You really should go
and talk to the people
at the National Museum
of Women in the Arts"
because they have a tremendous
artist book collection.
So, it's been an experience of,
you know, increased friendships
and growth and finding
out about new materials
and new technologies.
So, we had been married
about ten years
when Michael decided we should
do this first book because I,
as an academic, my
academic writing always came
with great difficulty.
But I always wrote poetry
from when I was little and,
the thing is, I never showed
it to very many people,
in fact, hardly anybody.
So, this is the first
book, "Forgotten contours"
which you've seen on the
table there, and which Mark
and the collection has.
And the paper, this handmade
paper from Pyramid Atlantic
that we've - I kind
of fell in love with.
And everything else was
done on our kitchen table.
So, our whole house is
basically a studio [laughter].
And the poem, this is a
favorite of mine at the time
in late, late 1990s and 2000s.
I had been going
through a lot of losses.
My son, that was back in
'95 and other close friends.
And so, a lot of the poem
- poetry that I was writing
at that time was poetry
about loss and about pain,
both personally and
then, thinking about it
in talking with, you know,
friends who were doing research
projects on, for example,
slavery, displacement,
migration.
These are also personal things
that touch us very deeply,
but they're also reflected
in the world around us.
And this is one of
those, the first poems.
Sorrow cuts so finely that, at
first, we do not feel its edge.
We wait for the joy
after sadness.
It is long in coming,
and we fear that we will
have forgotten its contours.
This, this is the end piece
of that - of that first book.
Michael, in the late
'90s, had done a series
of wonderful charcoal drawings
that I loved, based on a book
of South African photographs
of the Bushmen of South Africa.
And he began to do these
drawings and, I think,
making the - with the goal
of making the photograph more
of a personal statement.
And I think you can
see that in this one.
So, this was one of the ones
of that series that he did,
they were quite large.
And it's - the poem which is
I called, "Mother's Stories"
because my father died in '98
and my mother came to live
with us in D.C. And
she had some dementia,
probably not Alzheimer's
but, and anyway,
every day was a new day and
every hour was a new hour
and every minute
was a new minute.
>> Michael Platt: Literally.
>> Carol Beane: And
so, she would -
she would come downstairs
in the morning
and she was basically
our proofreader
because she would look at this
one was a favorite poem of hers.
She didn't make the connection.
So, this one is, Mother's
stories are long in telling.
I sometimes feel
the silent echoes
of resonances beyond
their daughter's knowing.
So, we wait and listen carefully
to fragments and nuances
and hope to be around when
they get in the friend -
with their friends in
the kitchen and begin
with the remember whens and
the, well, did I ever tell you,
and the, oh, you
should have seens.
Now, we have come more
fully to understand how
and why they still call each
other "girl" or some say cher.
But this is more
infrequent than we'd like.
And sooner, rather than later,
it is violated by illness
and failings and forgettings
and the falling away
of friends till there are few
with whom to sit and talk.
My mother would come
downstairs and she would say,
"I think I really
like this poem".
So, one day, Michael
said, "Oris,
that poem's about you,
don't you know that?"
[Laughter] And she
just kind of looked.
>> Michael Platt: Sometimes,
when she would come down,
I gave her the nickname
Old Eagle Eyes.
She was a third-grade
teacher in New York,
and she would find the mistake.
And I think I'm ready
for production, you know,
sometimes after I
printed the first one.
But she'll find it so I
used to call her Eagle Eyes.
But this was a really,
this book is probably one
of my favorite ones when I think
about the whole process,
the first one.
You know, it's like
always trying to get back
to our first high [laughter].
This is "Solitary Moments".
This was - usually, I
would do a set of drawings.
And the drawings I would work
on, or paintings or images
or prints I work from, usually
came from the preceding one.
So, a lot of times, it's not
with a specific subject matter
in mind, I just -
you work your way
into a [inaudible],
a theme, you know.
Solitary moments,
solitary mornings.
Most of these images are
40 by 60, they're large.
And it's been my experiences,
when you draw and you paint
and you print, coming up with
that right size that people,
so they won't be all in
the basement, you know.
So, but I hung on to this
40 by 60 which is, you know,
about that size, the size I am.
I got that from a
teacher up at Howard,
one of my favorite teachers
there, [inaudible] passed away.
And this is from a combination
of a courtyard in,
was it - in Africa.
And in Ghana in one
of the slave castles -
I call them slave castles.
And I like the textures
in the head.
In other words, I keep working
on these things till they feel
like my drawings
or my paintings.
[Inaudible].
>> Carol Beane: Put
it on vibrate.
>> Michael Platt: I'm
going to have to hit that.
I can't find anything.
>> Carol Beane: New
technologies.
>> Michael Platt: So, just like
a lot of the other mediums,
I keep putting thing -
putting things together,
overlapping images, overlapping
textures, overlapping figures,
overlapping spaces
till I find magic.
And, when that magic hits
you, sometimes it takes a lot
of nerve to stop and not
overdevelop the magic.
So, that's another thing I
got into, just I don't care
if it doesn't feel finished,
just stop because that's
when I feel the magic.
But sometimes you cheat and you
work on it a little bit more,
but that usually happens
around 4:00 in the morning.
Because I work -
I work at night.
And I pull out the
champagne, I won today.
Don't win every day, but you
do win every now and then.
You know, but most artists would
tell you, no matter what we say,
we've got a lot of stuff in
the basement that didn't work.
Most of the stuff
we do does not work.
I don't care what they say.
It's true.
All you've got to do, wait
till somebody dies and go
in their basement,
[laughter] see all
that stuff they didn't
get rid of.
>> Carol Beane: I just wanted
to say, too, that the first book
that we showed you, I had a body
of work that was done already
and Michael had the
images that he had worked.
So, that case, it was a matter
of seeing what went with what.
And sometimes, for the most
part, we were, I think, lucky.
The second - the second book was
some of that, but more writing
to the pieces, but
we definitely knew
that we didn't want
to illustrate them.
We just wanted a
feel back and forth.
This image, the model,
as it turned out, was,
I think her father was Nigerian.
But she just had a
tremendous presence about her.
And she - there's another
image of her in the portfolio
that you can see on the
side, if you didn't already.
And this was a poem
that goes with that,
I'd just like to
read that as well.
This refers to the
- our experience
of having visited the slave
castles or the slave factories
as they're known
in Elmina in Ghana.
Long after you are long gone
from the fettered dampness,
where accumulations of excrement
and other human waste remained,
monuments of the
minutia of survival,
where the excavator's chalk had
measured and marked the wall.
The corner farthest from the
door was its highest point.
There where dark flowers
stained and bloomed
on domed dungeon
ceilings and walls bloomed
with stained blossoms in
the darkness of high noon,
and blossomed at dusk with pale
blooms satining the darkness
dimly and staining
the midnight hours
of lightless days
with dark blossoms.
There, where the
people had been,
where spent heavy air had moved
slowly, overcome with sadness,
anguished at its own
insufficiency, there,
within those walls, where
the women had waited
and the men had waited and
the children who arrived who,
oft times, never left, had
waited, we stood and listened
to the weight of waiting.
This, again, is from the second
book, "Solitary Mornings".
And it came actually from
thinking about the stories,
memory talking with
older relatives,
listening to other
people's conversations,
eavesdropping sometimes
if you're riding
on the bus or in a public place.
And everyone has stories.
You have stories about your
life, your friends' lives,
what's happening,
what's not happening.
And my brother, who's very
interested in folklore
and anthropology, had
made a comment about some
of the storytellers that
he had been in contact
with from Ireland and Scotland.
And he said that there -
he told about one older man
who was the last one of
his generation and what
that means because,
then, it's all on you.
And that depends on to whom
have you told your stories.
Lest the stories be lost,
silhouettes of scars and joys.
Lest only one remain
conscious of the weight
of things long gone, talisman
against the chill of
solitary mornings.
Fragility is forbidden.
Now there is really no return.
>> Michael Platt: This image
here was, again, it's 40 by 60,
is one of few images where
I did what I really started
out to do was to
combine the digital
with traditional printmaking.
So, this is etching
in a digital piece.
And the idea was to do these
nice little, intricate,
little etchings which for
any times I like texture,
and to make it bigger.
Go back and work on some more.
But, somewhere along the line,
if it looks like a
duck, let it be a duck.
You know what I mean?
I really enjoyed the
digital so, why fight it?
Just go ahead and
do the digital.
The only thing I miss is getting
your hands dirty, you know?
People ask me, "Do you do
anything traditional now?"
I said, "Yes, I paint women".
Because all the models,
they come over to the house,
they get nude and I literally
take the paint and I paint them.
So, I'm still having
fun [laughter].
I'm still getting my
hands a little bit dirty.
"Abandoned Spaces", I like to
title because I like grunge.
I like shooting old places where
it looked like something used
to go on here and there's
a little bit of life left.
If you're ever in Philadelphia,
what is that, Eastern
State Prison?
>> Carol Beane: Penitentiary.
>> Michael Platt: Eastern
State Penitentiary.
Go there. I mean, it's -
it's - I can't tell you.
When you stand on
the outside, you say,
"What the hell is that?"
I don't want to go in there.
But it's a prison,
it's big, dark.
As big as a whole block.
And each cell is about -- .
>> Carol Beane: -- Six by nine.
>> Michael Platt: Six by nine.
There's only one light.
And they call it the Guard's
Eye and it's a skylight.
And it's hard to come out of
there with a bad photograph
because you've got
one light source.
And inside the place, they used
it all the way up to 1970s,
and it's gotten dilapidated.
And trees start growing inside
the cells and everything
so it's perfect for me.
I shot it with the attitude
I'm going to put something
in there digitally because I
like over raggedy buildings.
And I know, whenever I
shoot, I shoot textures
because I know I'm
going to put the texture
on something or in something.
If I shoot a space, I know
I'm going to put something
in the space, you know.
And the something is
usually these models.
And the models will come
over to the house, they say,
"What are we doing
today, Platt?"
I don't know sometimes,
we're jumping today.
So, how your knee?
What you talking
about, how my knee?
You know, so they
could be doing a lot
of jumping up and down today.
And then, eventually, I found a
place for that - for them to be.
You want to talk about this one?
>> Carol Beane: This particular
image that is there is -
was taken at Father Divine's
Hotel, the Divine Lorraine
which was probably one of the
first integrated hotels is
in Philadelphia in
the late '40s.
it was being, it had - it
went downhill and ended
up being not quite demolished,
but it was supposed
to be developed.
But then the - that particular
developer ran out of money,
and a friend of ours got
the salvage contract.
So, this is a 14-story building.
It had one-inch marble
steps on the men's wing
and the women's wing, but all
the way up to the 14th floor.
And all of the rooms, you
know, which you could see,
had old windows in it.
Sometimes, the beds and what
have you would then have been
left in it.
So, it was very stirring,
you know,
and you really felt
- felt a presence.
We decided not to
do the basement.
>> Michael Platt: No, we're
not going down in the basement.
>> Carol Beane: Basement,
basement was too scary.
You see, let me find this one.
Who comes quietly there?
There, where some have stood or
even waited these long years.
Where light must be will
itself to enter, vain dreams
and structures imbued
with tainted visions
that have not left,
nor will they ever.
They curl into fine
shreds tinged with regret
and the lost knowledge
of who you are.
This one, before
Michael changes it,
you when you see the actual book
we decided, we printed it out,
duplicate images and then did
some hand embellishments on it.
So, that, to me, really
gave an extra oomph to the -
both to the images
and to the words.
Again, the same - from
the same structure,
the old abandoned hotel.
I don't know, at some times,
I get my inspiration,
I go for a walk.
And it could be a word,
it could be a phrase,
could be something I
see and just the rhythm
of my steps has it repeating
in my head and then I,
if it feels like a really good
one, I try to write it down,
remember it and then write
it down when I go home.
And this - first line
of this one was one
of those such occasions.
She was dressed in the
many years of her existence
and wore rainbows
round her head.
She was adorned in
memories spattered with mud.
You could not read all
of where she'd been.
And tatters of her loves
clung to her restlessly.
That particular image,
I think, was inspired
by a woman whom I think
probably a homeless woman,
a woman on the way
to her shelter
or between different
points in her lives but come
down on her luck, that
I passed one morning
as I was going to school.
And she had this air, very
proud air still about her,
but she had her bags
and her layers of things
that had seen better days.
>> Michael Platt: Trans -- .
>> Carol Beane: -- Positions.
>> Michael Platt: Positions.
This was - we had the
opportunity to apply
for a public arts grant.
We didn't get it.
But it was about
- everyone knows
about how Foggy Bottom
Georgetown used to be black,
but they don't know
the whole story.
Carol, we investigated the part
about George Washington
University.
And all that over there used
to be hardcore poor
folks, Germans and -- .
>> Carol Beane: -- Irish.
>> Michael Platt: Irish
and black folks,
they were real poor.
And we looked for some areas,
we looked for some signs,
but they were just
Snow Court and -- .
>> Carol Beane: -- Hughes Mews.
>> Michael Platt: Hughes
Mews, we finally found them.
And there are little houses
there, they're about -
houses about this tall
and about that wide
with no bathroom, no
- nothing in them.
But they are fixed up
and gentrified right now.
But you - in D.C., you
walk in these alleys,
you can find little
places like that, you know,
that used to have a history.
And so, this is about the same
time when - not about the -
the ideas of gentrification
was on my head.
And it's still on my head
now, you know, because I kind
of think, why does
gentrification mean white?
You know what I mean?
It's just - and then, when
that happens, we're fixing up,
but all the flavor
in the neighborhood,
the reason why you - why
you live there is gone.
You know, no more
after-hour joints
after all the clubs close down.
No more, no more
corner stores, you know.
And the liquor store was -
they sold candy,
they sold everything.
They cash everybody's checks.
The hardware store
fixed everybody's locks
in the big apartment.
All that stuff goes away
when we gentrify, you know.
But that's not the end
of the story because,
if you live long enough, we
like to - I like to say I lived
through time, not stuck in time.
And so, this was about,
that area of George Washington
University, because we applied
for the grant at
the new library.
We didn't get the grant but,
just to make our
presentation good,
I decided to make this
book in one day [laughter].
And so, I stood up all night
and it got done, you know.
It was done.
And I say, "Well, this
is not bad", you know?
Not a bad book.
>> Carol Beane: Again, that
book, I think, is on the tables.
You can take a closer
look at it.
And this particular page that
it's turned to, with the figure,
so, and in the very substance of
bones broken, often unattended.
Of gnarled hands and discerning
whiplashes on hunched backs.
Is that image sort of
a public health thing
that wasn't able to happen?
It certainly wasn't happening
back in sort of 19th century
and coming into the 20th.
And this one figure that somehow
Michael did that really seemed
to combine that, that
lack, not only of service,
but just of general where
do you fit, you know,
and what do you deserve to have.
And the opposite page,
again, references an article
that I had read about
Georgetown shortly after I came
to D.C., I think, in '91.
So, it was probably mid '90s
in which they were talking
about people in Georgetown who
were in their gardening projects
and their landscaping were
turning up unexpectedly
for them, because they
didn't know the history,
but were turning up
bones, human remains.
And that was dated back to
that time when Georgetown was,
you know, an African
American community.
Burials uncovered, shifting
revelations of excavations
in now fine landscaped
gardens of gentile homes.
Specifics of daily life,
resistance, survival,
referencing and remembering
the implications
of displacement and replacement.
We mourn and celebrate
wood, stone, mortar,
brick, steel and glass.
Visions and revisions,
conjurings at our fingertips.
>> Michael Platt:
This is one public,
I think it's the
first one I ever got.
We were approached by a -
what's it called the group?
>> Carol Beane: I think the
American Association of Museums
that had their annual
meeting in D.C.
and the local committee
suggested to them
that they might want to consider
working with some artists
and having some actual
art as part of it.
So, the site selected was
the Old Soldier's Home,
also the site of
President Lincoln's cottage
in which he supposedly, and
probably did, hopefully,
write the draft of the
Emancipation Proclamation.
So, it had those were two
historical, sort of, points.
The one thing that we were
trying to do is we had done
with the Georgetown Project
that we felt was important was
to honor, bring to the fore the
African American participation
in the Civil War.
Down on U Street, there's
an African American museum.
There's also the African
American Civil War Monument
that has a lot of names.
And so, all of those
figured into our creation
of this particular
project which was -
which were two banners 40
feet long by 48 inches high.
And the challenge with
this particular project was
that they had many
committees in charge
of the Old Soldier's Home.
There's a committee for
trees, a committee for bushes,
a committee for the
buildings themselves.
If the building was
a certain date,
that was a different committee.
So, everything was very
well tended to and minded.
And there were two artists
groups, another husband
and wife team also, who
collaborated, but everything had
to pass through all the
committees before it could
go up.
So, to use nails or
not to use nails,
how do you hand something
on this?
And we figured everything
out, fortunately,
and also with the help
of some friends of ours
who are stagehands who
really knew certain tricks
of the trade to, you
know, to getting it up.
>> Michael Platt:
Martha Jackson Jarvis.
>> Carol Beane: Yeah,
Martha Jackson Jarvis, yeah,
and her daughter
and another friend,
Remy and some friends
of his came.
So, we all managed to get
it up and then, the next -
that evening, huge rain fell.
And with winds.
And so, you know, you wake
up in the morning and say,
"Shall I call or should we
wait for them to call us?"
And they called us.
And they said, "Well, you might
want to come up and look at it
because something's happened,
you know, to your banner."
So, we didn't know whether
something happened meant it was
down, you know, it was gone
or up in the trees or what.
But it was just minor damage
which we were able to fix up.
But the wonderful thing about
it visually was just the company
out in San Francisco
who did the work.
They do banners for places
like airports and so,
they know their products
very well.
The fabric on which
these things are.
And so, they said, "Well,
this material was used
in a banner at Miami Airport".
So, I said, "Okay,
we'll go with that".
But the translucency
of it was something
that we hadn't really
figured on.
So, the day that they had
the opening reception,
there was a wonderful
sunset which,
in some of the photographs
you can, you know, see a few.
But I did, I think, four
poems to go with that piece.
>> Michael Platt:
Oh, wait a minute.
>> Carol Beane: That's,
that's now the title,
you've got that there.
>> Michael Platt: Oh, yeah.
>> Carol Beane: Okay.
This is a - just a
brief statement because,
as we were going back again, a
project that went from one form
to the book, or to a book.
I thought that the first pages
of it were a little empty,
so I added this particular
phrase, turmoil
and suffering seeking freedom
respite sometimes beneath
a tree.
And the image on the front
is actually the oldest tree
on the site that
was probably there
when Lincoln was doing the
Emancipation Proclamation.
So, we took a picture of that
and then Michael
incorporated that in the image.
The image of the young
man known as a John Doe,
and I think that someone has
recently done some research
and they did manage
to identify him.
I don't know how.
One of the many people who have
worked with the collection here
at the Library, [inaudible] -- ?
>> Mark Dimunation: Yes.
>> Carol Beane: The
Civil War Collection.
One of the things
that I found out,
in terms of the participation
of African Americans
in the War were not only the
militia, the military people,
but also the support
personnel of course,
like nurses who probably
did the same job
as the doctors would
have been doing nowadays,
and other things.
This was one Susan Taylor
of whom there's an
image in the collection.
And this was what,
thinking about her
and what her life must have been
like, or might have been like,
or could have been like then.
Dawn, the stillness time
when night terrors move on
and healing balms and words
soothe pain and quiet fears.
The coolness of dew and fever
root, the sense of dreaming.
Peace bought in the early hours,
vanishing the stink of rot
and the rigors of death.
Compassion and life victorious
in those early morning moments
of the quietude of day.
>> Michael Platt:
Who was Miss Taylor?
>> Carol Beane: She
was the nurse.
Yeah, that's - oh, let's talk
about the bottom,
Michael [inaudible].
>> Michael Platt: Well, I
had a concept of, you know,
war goes on, more people die.
And we started the banner, there
was a few names at the bottom
and just piled up and it just
piled up and it just piled up.
But the other thing I thought
about was I'm 70, 71, you know,
so, I went to school in the '50s
and '60s, grade, undergraduate.
And, you know, the movies and
black and white T.V. And but,
in school, the only
thing we knew
about black folks was
George Washington Carver,
the peanut man.
And that was one paragraph.
And we had the history
book about this big.
But all this information
was out there,
it was then not important.
I don't know, what do you
mean, you're not important.
But it happened, you know.
The idea that somebody
would think
that everything connected
you and your life and people
like you, it just ain't
important, you know.
>> Carol Beane: Yeah.
>> Michael Platt: Yeah, you
know, but then you look at -
proud of the history
of the Caribbean.
Proud of the history
of Australia.
Is that - it's just
not important.
You know, so, the whole time,
you kind of make things
important by making them big.
I used to do this, before
I got into digital work,
I did a drawing and paintings
about black on black crime.
And my [inaudible] came,
they were about this big.
You know, and they
did it that small
because it just wasn't
important.
So, I would do it for
[inaudible], a piece on it.
But how can all this
information be out there
and you can't say you
didn't know about it.
It just wasn't important,
you know.
>> Carol Beane: I think one
of the things and, you know,
we're here in the Library
of Congress and you think
about libraries and I was
also thinking about the people
who commissioned the piece,
the Museum Association.
But these are all repositories.
And so, in the - you know,
that, in the warehouse somewhere
in some part of these
institutions
and these buildings, there are
- there is the information.
You know, the data, the data is
there which is why, you know,
research is so important.
And people who are doing it who
come with different perspectives
and different ways of thinking
about connecting the dots
that they find in
places like libraries.
And having access to the
bathrooms of museums, you know,
is so important to
be able to work with.
This was the last poem of that -
in that series, "The
Last Piece".
The - the figures in the
background are people who fled
from the South, who had come
to the D.C. area, most of them
because they had more
options, more possibilities,
both to get away from
enslavement but, also,
for either moving
North or participating
in some form in the war.
And many of the people
who are represented
in the photograph collections,
I think, are called conscripts.
So, they were people who
would have been freed during a
particular military operation.
Telling the children, you will
dance memories of feet waiting
in river waters, riding with
all those cast into the sea
on swells of moonlight.
Following those who leapt in
waded rivers under branches
of light and presence
you declare, I am.
We are in the midnight
hours and at high noon,
all those who died
journeying the deep waters
and the dusty roads protecting
shadows and claiming rhythms
of remembering in other places.
And these two poems,
this is, again,
a very well-known image
and, everybody who's been
to the new museum over on
14th Street, will recognize it
because it's one of
the key ones there.
And then, the John Doe because
that was how this young man
was identified.
And the flag, that one
has always hope for,
off to the right.
These two pieces
I wrote together
as a - kind of as a pair.
The one on the left with the
image of John Doe thinking
about the site for the exhibit.
And the one on the left,
a more open statement.
Place of solitude and solace,
place of sorrow and pain,
of reflection and introspection.
Now they cannot hear the
wind of all the trees remain.
Then they would have heard the
leaf songs, heard the work songs
and the sorrow songs, heard
and known the stories.
We have those carried
on the winds of memory.
Those set down note
by deliberate note,
word by weighted word.
We are the keepers of artifacts.
Their voices, their visions,
the culture of given peoples,
their spaces and times.
The truth of being and
creating, of the imagination
and the laying on of hands.
We stand together, we do,
on the edge of beginning.
You with your strength
of hard wood, red oak,
ash and southern pine.
I with the power of
waters and the wisdom
of my promise reflected
in midnight skies.
For the planting of seed
seasons we have come.
For the raising up
seasons and the falling
of the leaves seasons
and the gathering up
and the laying down
of dry limbs.
Under passion's roof in fields
and grasses fed with blood,
under wide skies and
trees grown old and wise.
Seen so much, seen too much.
We stand in hope
and dream and do.
We stand together in places
of solitude, sorrow and pain.
And, at the edges of beginning
in the solace of reflection.
We draw near in places
of solace, sharing grief
and desolation, sharing faith.
We know the tumult of
the edges of beginning
and the silences of endings.
Endings, thank you very much.
>> Unidentified Speaker:
Is there another one?
>> Carol Beane: Oh, yes.
>> Michael Platt: Nope, and
that's the end [laughter].
Hope you all enjoyed.
[ Applause ]
>> Michael Platt: Any questions?
Any questions?
Derek.
>> Derek: Did you talk
about your inspirations
and your inspirations
for images with thoughts
or words or by yourselves?
How is it that you then take the
- those inspirations together
when you do your collaborations?
What's the moment where you
talk about an aha moment
when you know that an image
works with that poetry
or when the poetry
works with an image?
>> Carol Beane: I think as we
were, as we were working on it,
particularly the first
book, we each had something
that we - that we loved.
You know, I had a phrase that I
thought was just really powerful
and Michael had an image
that he was, you know,
felt the same way about.
And sometimes he'd say, "Do you
have any words to go with this?"
You know, and I would
come and I would look
and I would either come back
with something or I'd say,
"Let me think about it" and then
come back with something later.
And sometimes I didn't have
any for that particular image.
And the same thing for him.
See, I still have a couple of
things that I've got, you know,
that I'd like to Michael
to do some images for.
My bus phone, for
example, is one.
But it's just - it was just
that it has been, so far,
just been basically that simple.
And it either, it
worked, it was okay.
And then a couple of - couple
of poems - I wrote one poem,
I was looking for something else
on the computer and I pulled
up this image that
Michael had been working on
and I hadn't seen it before
because we don't always,
I don't always show Michael
things that I write immediately.
Sometimes, it's a really
long time, like years.
And he has images that
he's constantly working on
or constantly changing,
so I don't always know
which version it is that maybe
he's trying to respond to.
And so, -- .
>> Michael Platt: -- Also -- .
>> Carol Beane: -- I
looked at it and this -
the poem just came out.
And then, afterwards, he told
me that it was a poem written
about a - it had been an
asylum for African American
who were considered
mentally ill in Patapsco.
It's called, you know,
"The Day We Were Set Free".
And I had no idea of knowing
that, but that's what it looked
like and it felt to me, so.
>> Carol Beane: I don't know
too many poets, but I got to -
I was introduced to
poets, Charles Blackwell
and Kenny Carroll and
The Wild Man, Gaston Neal
and he was the one
that really got Carol
out of the closet,
you know [laughter].
Don't do that nice stuff, come
on, you can give me some edge,
you know, that was Gaston.
But all the poets I know, they
had this big, raggedy book.
There's pages falling
all out, you know, they -
Carol would go upstairs,
this is before we got heavy
into the computer.
She'd go upstairs and
come back with this book.
And - I got something in here,
oh, it's in here somewhere.
But the deal is you always got
- you always have got to work.
You can't wait.
You've got to work.
I decided quite a few years ago,
you've got 20 minutes a day.
You do one thing
20 minutes a day,
you're going to get good at it.
You know, even exercise which I
haven't been doing [laughter] 20
minutes a day.
So, you - but we
always have something
to work from, not to work for.
>> Unidentified Speaker:
Will any of the things
in the basement, which I'm going
to take a closer look at now,
ever get resurrected
or reconfigured?
>> Michael Platt: Yeah, because,
you know, the other thing about,
not necessarily true with
drawing and painting,
but with printmaking
and digital print,
you've got prints
that don't work.
And you don't want
to throw them away
because you know damn well
you're going to cut that sucker
up and make a [inaudible].
But you never quite
seem to get to that
because you're still thinking
about the new image, you know.
And sometimes, when you
work on an old image, you -
your brain goes back
to that old time again.
I don't know how
to get past that.
What's the fellow
in New Orleans?
John Scott?
He was the only dude I've seen
that took a bunch of old prints
that didn't work, cut them up
and do collages out of them.
And it worked.
All printmakers think
about doing that, you know,
because that's why they don't
throw away nothing [laughter].
E.J., you don't throw
away anything [laughter].
You know, because it's going
to happen one day, you know,
we're going to -
it's going to happen.
>> Unidentified Speaker:
Just reprint on top of it.
>> Michael Platt: Well, we're
going to - we're going to deal
with those old things.
I don't know how we're going
to deal with it, you know,
maybe the canvas
we're going to work
on would be the size
of that wall.
You know, and play Romare
Bearden and just cut
that sucker out, put it up there
and see what happens, you know.
>> Unidentified Speaker:
And put it back
in the printer, print it again.
>> Michael Platt: Yes,
Mr. Green [laughter].
That's what we good for.
>> Unidentified Speaker:
I was curious
about the portfolio
on the table.
Have you done several
portfolios?
And were they done at the
same time as the books?
>> Michael Platt:
Portfolios, again,
not all portfolios had words
on them - have words on them.
This portfolio, here, was
a direct response to the -
a trip to Ghana when
I saw those castles,
slave castles I call them.
And I shot one for two hours.
But, to me, they were just
stage sets and textures
and I just knew I'm
going to jump
on this soon as I get back home.
The portfolios with
that printmaking thing
of small pieces or
people with little money.
I always had this thing with
making my work accessible.
So, I would do a portfolio
of small eight by -- .
>> Carol Beane: -- Tens.
>> Michael Platt: Eight by
tens for a lot of the shows.
And I'd put them together.
And that's how, you know, that
- I never quite got it together
about how to make
money in art, you know.
That's why I taught school.
That's why most people I know
who are artists,
they teach school.
I think that some of
us are fortunate enough
to make a living out of this.
Because we weren't - at
our age, we weren't taught.
It was just through osmosis,
you'd get out there and you go
into that gallery over there.
They tell you, "No".
Then you go to the next
gallery, they tell you, "No".
You do that for about two years,
maybe somebody might say, "Yes".
They see you coming in the
door with that big portfolio,
they know, [sniffing] student.
Come back, come back later,
two years, [laughter] you know.
And you don't get discouraged,
you just keep going.
But, today, they a little
bit more on the game of how
to make a living out of this.
And, thanks to computers,
YouTube - I call it YouTubeU,
you can learn everything
on YouTube right now.
You can - just so much
information out here right now
that wasn't out there
when I was, you know.
>> Carol Beane: You
had a question?
>> Unidentified Speaker: Yeah.
I was interested in
how much of your work
or [inaudible] combination,
how much of it is based
on historical events and
places that you visited
such as the slave castles
you called them in Ghana.
And how much is it based on
like the day-to-day observations
like you were mentioning this
woman that you saw walking?
Is it like 50/50 or do you find
that you're more [inaudible]
to historical aspects of
the work that you would do
or that you base
your work off of?
>> Michael Platt: A lot
of times, my work is based
on where I'm going
to where I travel to.
And, usually, through these
African what's the conferences?
>> Carol Beane: Literature
Association.
>> Michael Platt: African
Literature Association,
had something to do
with black folks.
I always - I always ask her,
"Take me, take me, take me".
You know, I'd find
something to do.
>> Carol Beane: No,
that - that - wait, no,
that happened because, those
of you who may be printmakers,
there's a Southern Graphics
Printmaking Conference is one
that Michael used to go to.
He would see [inaudible] there
and, you know, other folks.
And there would be this product
fair and Michael would come back
and he'd always be - he would
always have such a good time.
So, I said, "I need to
go to one of those".
So, I went to one of those
and then we began, you know,
exchanging so that -
that worked out well.
Sylvia.
>> Sylvia: So, are - have you
written a book about yourselves,
or just documented you?
Because, you know, while you're
alive and you have your memory.
>> Michael Platt:
That's very good.
I like that [laughter].
>> Carol Beane: We've, you know,
Michael has his show that's
upcoming at the [inaudible]
for which he'll be a catalog.
And we had talked a number of
years, a couple - maybe two
or three years ago about doing
a book about Michael, doing it.
So, we've got - but, about the
two of us, I guess, you know,
I used to never tell
anybody that I was a poet.
I used to not tell anybody
that I wrote poetry.
I had a - the people
I learned Portuguese
from had a very good poet
friends, they're both academics.
And they work in Brazilian
literature and they told one
of their friends, who
was a poet in Brazil,
about their friend,
me, who wrote poetry.
So, I would send
some things down so,
sometimes I would get very
daring and I would try
to write poetry - well,
I wouldn't write it
in Spanish, but Portuguese.
And so, I would always call
them poemoids, you know,
I couldn't bring myself to,
you know, take ownership.
But, again, Michael and
our friend, Gaston Neal,
were the two people who,
you know, put the rope
around my wrist or whatever part
of me and sort of dragged me
to read, you know, before
more than one person.
And, you know, I'm very grateful
for that and all the friends
who have listened to
me, you know, over,
you know, over the years.
And [inaudible] Christina
Wasserman is one
and Juliet Bethea [phonetic]
and sometimes at the gallery
that represented Michael,
if he would present some
of these pieces like these,
the portfolio's pieces
were like four by six.
And so, he exhibited all
of those in the gallery
and I read the poems
that went with them.
And, after a while, you begin
to say, "Yes, this is something
that I do, you know, that's me".
So.
>> Unidentified Speaker: But
I mean, like, in terms of -- .
>> Carol Beane: -- But in
terms of ongoing documentation
and both by what
you did with E.J.,
example, and other people -- .
>> Unidentified: -- Because -
well, what I mean, in terms of,
you know, setting a model
for African American young
artists because, you know,
you're always looking at
other people's stories.
And it would be a great read.
Like, you know.
>> Michael Platt: That's
something to think about.
>> Carol Beane: Yeah.
>> Unidentified Speaker:
They are open to it,
but they need someone
to pen it for them.
>> Carol Beane: Yeah.
Well, yeah.
And my friend and
former student,
my son by another mother, from -
who I've known really
a long time,
one of my students way back
when when I was teaching
at Bryn Mawr, has been after
me to do something like that.
In fact, we have kind
of a joint project set.